[Applause]
uh president Donald Trump let me let me
just throw out a list of some of the
significant issues that we're facing as
a country and and you've touched on a
number of them uh you mentioned borders
day one you mentioned energy day one uh
look at where our economy is last year 2
trillion in debt 38 trillion over uh 34
trillion overall we this year Mr
President will pay before we spend a
dime $1
trillion on debt service alone before
medic care Social Security National
Defense that is unsustainable yeah so
before Co hit us our gift uh from China
that was our gift what happened to us
with Co commonly known as the China
virus they don't like that but it was a
China
virus we were doing energy taking our
liquid gold out of the ground at a rate
that's never been seen before and it was
going up we were going to be using that
Liquid Gold to sell to Europe instead of
the pipeline from Russia which I exposed
and I stopped you know I stopped that
line then they say I was nice to Russia
there was nobody that was nice I was not
nice to Russia I stopped that pipeline
we would have been selling oil and gas
to Europe to Asia all over the world we
would have been paying off debt that
debt would be way down right now because
we have more what people don't know we
have more Liquid Gold than any other
country in the world by far and we
started off in fourth place we were
number four it was Saudi Arabia it was
Russia was two countries fighting for
number three and it was us at number
four or five by the time I left we were
number one by 25% we would have been
number one by a 100 and we would have
done twice what they were going to do
combined we would have been paying off
debt and we would have been reducing
taxes we gave you the biggest tax cut in
the history of our country bigger than
the Reagan tax cut we would have been
reducing taxes still further and that's
why Sean that's why we had the most jobs
of any president ever because we gave
the we got rid of regulations tremendous
no president got rid of more regulations
or close and we gave you the big tax cut
so everybody had incentive and everybody
was happy and everybody was working I
remember groups came to see me that
wouldn't normally like me and they said
we've never seen anything like it we
were actually starting to get along that
we got hit with the China virus we were
some people think purposely I don't I
think it was in competence but some
people think purposely because we were
doing so much better than any other
country ever and we got hit but I will
tell you we would be paying that debt
off right now at levels like never seen
before and would have been beautiful
thing you brought us to energy
Independence for the first time in 75
years before you ran I remember we had
many discussions about energy
independence energy Independence and
you're saying that you would in a second
term you will push America to be the
most energy dominant country on Earth
and that you could pay down that $34
trillion in debt and we won't have a
trillion dollar interest payment every
year that's right we would get it way
down and you know
look
so it's Biden inflation that's what it
is what he did with energy is
unbelievable because energy went up so
much gasoline $5 $6 a gallon that that's
what caused inflation now it's all over
the place but you have
29% total inflation now when it holds up
because the economy is starting to slow
down very substantially so when it holds
up he's saying well we don't have too
much inflation but he doesn't talk about
all of the inflation that you've had to
suffer over the last three years no we
will have numbers like you've never seen
we have a thing in Alaska called anoir
Ronald Reagan tried to get it approved
everybody Bush maybe a little bit you
know he didn't work as hard but we have
we have anoir in Alaska the biggest
anywhere in the world including probably
Saudi Arabia I got it approved I was so
proud of it they ended it in the first
week they ended it they turn we'll get
it back but we have more than anybody we
have more wealth than anybody but we
don't use it and then guys like Dan
santis and guys like many of the
Democrats but guys like Dan santis and
to a lesser extent Nikki Haley they want
to play around with your Social Security
you don't have to touch Social Security
we have money laying in the ground far
greater than anything we can do by
hurting senior citizens with their
social
security Ronda santis wanted to bring up
on Social Security now of course he says
well I wouldn't but you know one thing I
learned about politicians I've known
them I've dealt with them on the other
side for a long time their first thought
is always the thought that they go to he
wanted to raise the minimum age the age
on Social Security to 70 that's a big
increase but he also wanted to raise it
to 75 if that happened people would be
devastated we have such incredible
wealth under our feet hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else